ils ont deux heures pour élaborer la
viennoiserie préféré des français
quinze apprentis venus de toute la
région vont devoir démontrer leur talent
de phase honneur du croissant au beurre
donc là c'est surtout une technique de
tours âge donc donc c'est
l'incorporation de feuilles successives
de beurre et de pâtes qui fait donc
notre feuilletage et ensuite donc
détaillé en triangle bien les rouler de
façon à obtenir un enroulement de pâques
pour obtenir donc le volume on va dire
un peu plus importants au centre que sur
les côtés pour pouvoir donc leur donner
la forme de croissant nicolas est en
quatrième année au cfa de châteauroux et
ce candidat très exigeants n'est pas
très content de lui lire sur les côtés
ils sont irréguliers ils sont ils
devaient tomber ils font plus courbé ils
font faillite aimé profiter
lucie en terminale hôtellerie à blois
doute aussi de sa cuisson d'autant
qu'elles mesurent tout l'enjeu de ce
concours ça montrerait que le travail
fourni les récompenser toutes les heures
qu'on a passées à s'entraîner ça en
valait la peine et que on a donné le
meilleur de nous mêmes et finalement le
résultat n'est pas si mal ils sont un
peu déchiré du coup c'est dommage parce
qu'ils sont retombées mais il ya du
feuilletage du coup qu'en fin de mois
les dés sont jetés le jury évalue la
brillance le feuilletage et surtout le
goût les deux vainqueurs du cfa2 tour
participeront à la finale nationale le
18 mai prochain
nicolas lui a fini troisième pas si mal
pour un premier concours